from Zachary professor Knowles my 16
year old little sister is starting to be
influenced by her lefty friends in high
school and is questioning why she should
be a Republican Republicans are of
course mean and illogical luckily she's
open-minded and wants to chat with me
about my conservative values how should
I begin my explanation of conservatism
to my little sister help it's not too
late your little sister is in high
school she's being influenced by her
lefty friends
that's good that's the time for that the
time to believe lefty thoughts is when
you're a teenager and you don't know
anything and then when you know things
then you'll move further to the right I
even went through a little bit of this
phase when I was in high school because
these left-wing thoughts are appropriate
to children who are both arrogant and
uneducated and then hopefully you can
work on both of those things over time
and you will move further to the right
I'm sure I wouldn't you have it down her
throat though I would I would rather I
would take almost like a meta political
approach to this and ask her why she's
so confident that these dummies are
right and why these things that she's
learning or right
probably the curriculum that she's
studying from is teaching her a lot of
nonsense and the people don't know very
much and it's an age where you're just
insufferable so I wouldn't give her too
much grief for that I would I would
point out that all of those people and
all of these assumptions she's taking
for granted or they're on shaky ground
the poem that comes to mind is a little
learning is a dangerous thing
drink deep or taste not the pure Ian
Spring they're shallow drafts intoxicate
the brain and drinking largely Sobers us
again so bill Whittle talks about this
he says there's Island 129 island 120 of
this around IQ of 120 you know and it's
people it's like the New York Times
editorial board the New York Times op-ed
columnist they all have a kind of
middling intelligence and they are
extremely left-wing and people of kind
of middle intelligence they they're like
yeah man they're totally right
oh man a David Brooks oh yeah the Paul
Krugman they're really speaking to me
and people who have lower intelligence
or higher intelligence are both
conservative
they're more conservative it's a
sandwich but it's just people in the
middle who don't realize how stupid they
are but they're smarter than your
average Joe they're the ones who are
convinced of lefty stuff I would I would
go to that you know and then you can
tell her to read
I don't know Edwin Burke or Bill Buckley
or whatever but in the meantime I would
have her look around and say are these
people really so smart are these ideas
that you're being told really so
convincing or is it just fashionable and
teenagers are contrarian and that might
get to her